[MUSIC PLAYING]
One of the most
interesting articles
I've come across in the
last couple of years
is Alain de Botton's article
on the fact that museums
need to do a better
job at creating spaces
that trigger encounters
with the sacred.
In other words, he thinks
that we need better secular
institutions in which to
experience the transcendent.
Human beings long for these
encounters with the epic,
to rub up against the numinous.
We wake up and we want
our lives to have meaning.
So we go to church on Sunday.
We look at beautiful
cathedrals and experience
some kind of awe, whether
or not we are believers.
The spaces themselves
seem to induce it.
And religions
understand this well.
But do secular institutions?
I mean, aside from
the movie theater,
aside from the IMAX
screen occasionally
playing a film like Inception
and conjuring up the cosmic awe
that only brilliant
sci-fi can conjure,
we don't have that many
spaces for this kind of stuff.
You know, there was an article
called "Golden Eye," written
by Ross Andersen, that spoke
of the Hubble Space Telescope
and how it was an
instrument of man.
It was the eye of
man, an exoskeleton
of man's optic nerve,
literally allowing
us to mainline the whole of
time through the optic nerve.
And it does allow us to do that.
The Hubble,
instruments of science
that expand what we can see,
they do expand our minds.
They do help us rub up
against the numinous,
the intricate order, the
pattern that connects.
This is the thing
that these things do,
but only under certain
compressed modes
of presentations.
If it wasn't for Ross
Andersen's overly articulated
poetic distillation of
what the Hubble does,
I might not have
thought of it that way.
If I didn't have
the context in which
to understand the
role of the Hubble
in expanding human
consciousness,
I might not have been able
to appreciate it fully.
And so, again, going back
to the Alain de Botton idea,
how can we create more spaces,
more institutions, more
interfaces that mediate our
encounters with the epic,
our encounters with the sacred?
Because we need that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]